THE JUNE TO JUNE TWELFTH LABOR
EMPLOYMENT NEED ORDER IF WE CAN --
MADAM SECTOR CALL ROLE PLEASE
REFORM.
KALRA HERE FLORA.
CARILLO.
YEP.
GONZALEZ PRESIDENT JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
SO -- IF WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
MOTION ON ITEMS THREE AND FOUR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR REMOVED
SECOND -- METACENTRIC HOLLOW
PLEASE.
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE AND SB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT MOTION IS DO PASS
CONSENT TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA FLORA
I AGREE UP.
YET.
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I THE
THREE OF US.
OKAY THANK GOD IS OUT.
OF A GOING TO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE ON THE FILE ACA FOURTEEN IS
AMERICA'S HOUSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSUS.
AC FOURTEEN IS SIMPLY A
RESOLUTION THAT ASK THE VOTERS
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENSURE ALL
WORKERS WHO PERFORM SUPPORT
SERVICES AT THE UC ARE FOR THE
SAME.
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
STANDARDS AS THE UC EMPLOYEES.
BEYOND PROVIDING WORLD CLASS
INSTRUCTION AND RESEARCH AT ITS
CAMPUSES IN MEDICAL CENTERS THE
YOU SEE THE STATE'S THIRD
LARGEST EMPLOYER AND IT'S AN
ANCHOR IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH IT OPERATES.
IN RECENT YEARS THE UC HAS
OUTSOURCED AN ESTIMATED SEVEN
THOUSAND SUPPORT JOBS WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF HIGHLY PAID
ADMINISTRATORS TO APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHT THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THIS
RESULTED IN AN ANNUAL MINISTRY
PAYROLL COST INCREASE OF SIXTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS AMOUNT NOW.
THANK YOU SEE HAS PREVIOUSLY
ESTIMATED WOULD COST TO OFFER
OUTSOURCED WORKERS THE FULL
PROTECTIONS AN EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS ENJOYED BY
THE UC EMPLOYEES.
ACA FOURTEEN WILL PROTECT
SERVICE WORKERS THAT YOU SEE
FROM POLICIES THAT PRODUCE
ECONOMIC RACIAL AND GENDER
DISCRIMINATION. TO BE CLEAR
NEITHER THE LEGISLATURE NOR THE
GOVERNOR CAN ADDRESS A
SYSTEMATIC INEQUALITIES THAT
OCCUR TO THE UC'S ECONOMY UNDER
ARTICLE NINE OF THE CONSTITUTION.
HOWEVER ARTICLE TO THE
CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE THE POWER AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALLOW VOTERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE.
I SIMPLY ASK THAT YOU ALLOW THE
VOTERS TO DECIDE WHETHER LOW
INCOME SERVICE WORKERS THAT YOU
SEE THOSE WHO CLEAN THE TOILETS
MOW THE LAWN SERVE OUR FOOD AND
CLEAN THE BED PANS SHOULD ENJOY
THE SAME STANDARDS.
ENJOYED BY UC EMPLOYEES DOING
THE SAME WORK.
THE WITNESSES HERE THANK YOU
SAME MEMBER AND AS AS PRACTICE --
THIS COMMITTEE OF THE SITE CAN
HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES SPLIT UP
ANYWAY -- THAT THE PROPONENT
CHOOSES WITH THE PUNCHES WHEN
THAT TIME COMES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAPTION WHY BURGER
PRESIDENT OF APPS ME THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE I I HAVE HAD THE
CHANCE TO MEET WITH MANY OF THEM
OUT.
I IN I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR THE SEVERAL OF YOU WHO
HAVE CO AUTHORED -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR DOING SO.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN A CA FOURTEEN ARE DOING
THE DIRTIEST WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
CLEANING THE TOILETS.
EMPTYING THE BED PANS PICKING UP
TRASH.
WE ARE WORKING CLASS BLUE COLLAR.
WE COOK THE FOOD MAINTAIN
BUILDINGS AND SUPPORT THE
DOCTORS NURSES FACULTY AND
STUDENTS AT UC.
WE ARE CLEANING FIXING AND
HELPING TO MAKE ONE OF OUR
GREATEST EDUCATIONAL AND PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS RUN.
AND SUCCEED.
WE'RE ALSO.
THE INVISIBLE BUT ESSENTIAL
PEOPLE AT UC.
WE ARE THE ONES IN YOUR
DISTRICTS TRYING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET WE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN YOU MAKE POLICY AROUND FOR
ABILITY HOUSING?
AND HEALTH CARE.
AND YET THE PUBLIC STANDARD AND
PRACTICE HAS BEEN THAT WE ARE TO
BE TREATED LESS THAN NOT EQUAL
TO EVERYONE ELSE AT UC.
WE ARE THE ONLY GROUP OF
EMPLOYEES BEING OUTSOURCED AT
THE GREATEST RATE AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
WERE SEPARATELY DO NOT HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THIS.
SO I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER PLACING
THIS ISSUE ON THE BALLOT. FOR
YOUR VOTERS TO DECIDE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS ARTHUR LOU
I AM SIMPLY HERE TO SERVICE
RESOURCE THERE AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE IS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WITH THE CHAIR BRIAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES HERE STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL ALSO STRONG
SUPPORT OF OUR AFFILIATE.
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS CURTIS LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JOHN RENDON I'M THE
VP OF LEGISLATION FOR THE UC F.
T. THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
LIBRARIES ELECTRICITY WAS A
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
HONORABLE TEARING MEMBERS AMY
HEINZ SHAKE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSIONAL.
MAYES COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINETY ONE
NINETEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
IMPROV CHAMBERS AND SISTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN WEIGHING ON HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BUT IS THERE IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND AS I PREVIOUSLY SAID YOU
HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES PUT UP
ANY WAY YOU CHOOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
MR CHAIRED MEMBERS -- JASON
MURPHY ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HERE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES -- FROM YOU SEE
HEALTH -- AS AND OTHERS -- IN
STRONG OPPOSITE TO IS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL SORRY -- I WANT TO
STATE FOR THE RECORD THAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TAKES ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES TO MAINTAIN A
STABLE IN HOUSE WORKFORCE VERY
SERIOUSLY -- AND TO UTILIZE
CONTRACTORS FOR SPECIFIC
BUSINESS PURPOSES -- IN A
LIMITED AND RESPONSIBLE MANNER --
AS YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY HAS A
UNIQUE MISSION -- OF TEACHING
RESEARCH AND AND UNIVERSITY SIX
TO ADDRESS THIS BALANCE BY
ENSURING THROAT CLICK THE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS THAT THERE
ARE.
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE --
DISPLACEMENT IS NOT A PROBLEM
WITHIN HOUSE STAFF OF THE
UNIVERSITY HAS IN OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT
CONVERSATIONS.
A LANGUAGE THAT PREVENTS
UNIVERSITY FROM CONTRACTING OUT
SOLELY TO SAVE MONEY.
OUR AND SO THEREFORE -- THE
UNIVERSITY DOES CONTRACT OUT IN
SITUATIONSWHERE WE NEED SPECIAL
EXPERTISE -- SPECIAL EXPERIENCE --
FOR SITUATIONS WHERE SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT IS REQUIRED AND THE
LIKE -- AS SUCH WE ADDRESS THE
CYCLICAL AND EPISODIC --
WORKLOAD NEEDS FOR CIRCUMSTANCES
SUCH AS CLEAN OUT OF RESIDENTS
HALLS AT THE END OF THE TERM --
CLEAN UP AFTER SPORTING EVENTS
AND SO FORTH THAT ARE HELD FROM
TIME TO TIME AS WELL AS
PERFORMING SUCH ACTIVITIES LIKE
MAINTENANCE AND OTHER TYPES OF
LANDSCAPING NEEDS.
THAT REQUIRE -- SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT I'M THINKING OF TREE
TRIMMING THINGS LIKE THAT HERE.
AGAIN I WANT TO REITERATE.
YOU SEE DOES NOT DISPLACE
WORKERS AS RESULT OF CONTRACTING
OUT IN FACT OF THE RANKS OF THE
UNION REPRESENTED WORKFORCE OF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS -- NINE
POINT 9% OF LOOK AT THE ASPEN
NUMBERS A PARTICULAR SEVENTEEN
POINT 1% IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
OF GROWTH IN THE NUMBERS OF REPS
EMPLOYEES IN THOSE PARTICULAR
CATEGORIES.
I KNOW THIS ISN'T FISCAL
COMMITTEE BUT I WOULD POINT OUT
REAL QUICKLY THAT THE UNIVERSITY
IS PACKED THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL AT A HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
AS A RESULT IN SOURCING PREMIUM
WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY -- THE
UNIVERSITY ALSO ONCE MAKE CLEAR
THAT WE UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
BY OUR EMPLOYEES WE DO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH OUR
LABOR PARTNERS.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING STEADILY
AT THE COLLECTIVE BARGAIN TABLE
TO RESOLVE A LOT OF THESE EXACT
ISSUES OF RACE IN THIS BILL WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT TO ADDRESS THESE --
CONCERNS AND PUT IN A CA -- INTO
A FACT ONLY WOULD TIE THE HANDS
OF BOTH OUR UNIVERSITIES INNER
LABOR PARTNERS TO SOLVE THESE
LABOR ISSUES GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ANGELA KELLY ARE.
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
HEALTH POLICY FOR YOU SEE HEALTH
THE MISSION OF YOU SEE HEALTH
SYSTEMS IS TO ADVANCE THE HEALTH
OF SOCIETY.
THROUGH HEALTH RELATED EDUCATION
RESEARCH PATIENT CARE SERVICES.
YOU SEE IS FIVE NATIONALLY
RANKED ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS
IN EIGHTEEN HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOLS NEARLY 50% OF MEDICAL
STUDENTS.
AND MEDICAL RESIDENTS ARE
TRAINED IN CALIFORNIA USED.
HAMMERS ARE FINANCIALLY SELF
SUSTAINING AND THE INCOME
GENERATED BY THE UC MEDICAL
CENTERS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO OUR PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOLS.
OUR MEDICAL CENTERS ARE PUBLIC
SAFETY NET HOSPITALS THAT MUST
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN TO ALL
PATIENTS IN SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUSLY ILL.
PATIENTS NEEDING HIGHLY COMPLEX
CARE EVERY HOSPITAL INCLUDING
YOU SEE MUST HAVE MECHANISMS TO
ACHIEVE FLEXIBLE STAFFING TO
RESPOND TO CHANGES IN PATIENT
SENSES AND ACUITY ON A DAILY.
AND EVEN SHIFT BY SHIFT BASIS
THAT DEMAND HIGHER LEVELS OF
STAFFING.
CHANGES IN PATIENT ACUITY AND
SENSES REQUIRE ADJUSTMENTS TO
NOT ONLY PATIENT CARE STAFF SUCH
AS VOCATIONAL NURSES PATIENT
LIFT AND PATIENT TRANSPORTATION.
TECH TRICK PATIENT TRANSPORT
TECHNICIANS BUT ALSO TO CRITICAL
OPERATIONS SUPPORT LIKE STAFF.
STAFF LIKE JANITORS FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS AT CETERA OUTBREAKS OF
CONTAGIOUS ILLNESSES SURGES IN
TRAUMA CASES AND CONTINUAL
CHANGING CONDITIONS IN MIX OF
ADMITTED PATIENTS CONSTRAIN
EXISTING STAFF.
THE RESTRICTIONS ESTABLISHED FOR
A CA FOURTEEN WHAT IS WOULD
PREVENT YOU SEE HOSPITALS FROM
BEING ABLE TO OBTAIN THE STAFF
THEY NEED.
AND THIS KIND OF POLICY IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE STATE WE
THINK ON ANY PUBLIC INSTITUTION
AND WOULD FORCE AND AND IN
PARTICULAR HOSPITALS WOULD FORCE.
US TO DIVERT.
AWAY FROM THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
TRAUMA CENTERS AND COULD CAUSE
US TO CANCEL AND RESCHEDULE
IMPORTANT.
MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
LASTLY USUALLY HOSPITALS ARE
HIGHLY REGULATED IN OPERATE IN A
HIGHLY COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT
POLICY DECISIONS LIKE ACA
FOURTEEN CAN HAVE A LONG TERM
EFFECT.
ON OUR SUSTAINABILITY AS MEDICAL
CENTERS IT WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO TRAIN THE
NEXT GENERATION OF DOCTORS AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
AND THEREFORE WE DO OPPOSE.
HOW MANY CANCER MANY OF ONE
FIFTEEN ALL RIGHT ALL TRYING TO
MY BEST?
COMING AT IT FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T
DUPLICATOR OR EVEN SPEAK TO SOME
OF THE STATISTICS OF THE UC
PROVIDER -- PROVIDERS JUST SAID
WE'RE COMING OUT FROM THE
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY PROVIDES THE CONTRACTS
THAT -- THE YOU SEE -- UTILIZES
FOR THE SUPPORT SERVICES I WOULD
SUGGEST SUGGEST IT'S NOT JUST A
LIMITATION THIS IS.
POTENTIALLY A BAN ON THE USE OF
CONTRACTING -- ONE BECAUSE IT
SAYS YOU HAVE TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND GET
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR ANY
CONTRACT INTO ONLY IF YOU DO
THAT CAN YOU HAVE TEN DAYS OF
EMPLOYMENT RIGHT UNDER THAT
CONTRACT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WHAT BUSINESSES
OR GOING TO WAIT ONE FOR A
POTENTIALLY A WHOLE LEGISLATIVE
CYCLE TO GET APPROVAL FOR A
CONTRACT OR TWO AFTER WAITING
THAT LONG -- IN THAT TIME PERIOD
TO ONLY WORK FOR THAT CONTRACT
FOR TEN DAYS IT'S NOT
FINANCIALLY AND AS SENATE FOR
THE CON.
COMPANY TO DO IT SO ESSENTIALLY
I WOULD SUGGEST THIS IS A BAND
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
BILL WOULD EVEN WORK WITH
RESPECT TO ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
SAYS.
THAT YOU CAN HAVE A CONTRACT
REFORM SUPPORT SERVICES IT'S IT
ON IT ANTICIPATED SPECIAL EVENT
TO THE UNIVERSITY WITH THIRTY
DAYS LIMITED NOTICE HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE THAT WITH THAN HAVING
TO GO BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
TO GET APPROVAL FOR THAT
CONTRACT AND BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT SITUATION THAT ON
ANTICIPATED EVENT WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS SO I THINK IT'S A CHALLENGE.
SO WILL POTENTIALLY IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR LOSE JOBS BUT
FROM A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT OUR
COMPANIES HAVE IS THE WORK FORCE
IN BEING ABLE TO HAVE AN
EDUCATED AND DEDICATED WORK
FORCE AND TO THE EXTENT YOU
RESTRICT THE BUDGET OF THE UC.
LIMIT THEIR ABILITY TO DEVOTE --
FUNDING TO THE SOURCES OF
EDUCATION PROFESSORS US SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
PROVIDE THAT EDUCATION AND
EFFICIENT A FISSION AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH HOW THAT WILL
IMPACT OF THE GROWING AND I'D
TRAINED WORKFORCE -- THAT WE
RELY UPON SO FROM THOSE REASONS
WE ARE POST THANK YOU -- ANY
OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZE ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE
NAME FILIATION POSITION.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND WE ARE OPPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MAURICE RIDGES AND ON BEHALF.
MASON AND DUE TO OUR CONCERNS --
FOR PATIENT SAFETY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY -- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS THOUGHTS EMOTIONS.
DO WE MOVE THE BILL TO MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU IS THERE A SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF SO.
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO ADD ME ON AS A AS A CO
AUTHOR.
IF I HADN'T DONE IT ALREADY
THANK YOU ARE BUT YEAH OKAY THIS
IS FOR JUST MAKE SURE WHAT WILL
MATTER.
I MAY HAVE BEEN WAITING HE'S NOT
YET BUT HE IS NOW YEAH I MAY
HAVE BEEN WAITING.
UNTIL YOU AT IT THE REAL PROBLEM.
WHICH WAS GOING TO THE VOTERS.
TO CHANGE THE TENURE OF A THE UC
REGENTS WHICH I CONSIDERED A
REAL PROBLEM.
LOOK THAT THEY CAN OUTLAST THREE
GOVERNORS INTO LEGISLATURE'S.
ONLY KINGS QUEENS AND DICTATORS
HAVE THAT MUCH.
TENURE IN THE WORLD.
AND SO THEY CAN IGNORE US.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE TO COME
BACK TO US.
THE TALK WITH HIS DAVID DONE IT
IN THE PAST.
THAT PARTY UC REGENTS.
I WORK FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES FOR FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
I WORK FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES I
WAS WERE WITH. ONE SEVEN BROUGHT
IN. NINE TIMES OUT OF TEN WE DID
A MUCH BETTER JOB.
THEN THE PRIVATE SECTOR NINE
TIMES OUT OF TEN AFTER YOU
HIGHER TO MAKE THE LOWER COSTS
WITH THE CHANGE ORDERS AND THE
OTHER THINGS THAT CAME IN LATER.
AFTER FIVE TEN YEARS YOU'RE
PAYING MORE THAN YOU DID WITH
THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
BUT THAT'S NEVER INCORPORATED.
AND MY POINT IT SHOULD BE ME BUT
THERE'S NEVER INCORPORATED IN
THE ANALYSIS IS USUALLY AT THE
FRONT END THIS IS HOW MUCH WE
SAFE.
BUT NO ONE EVER DOES AN ANALYSIS
OF HOW MUCH THEY ULTIMATELY
SPENT ON THE BACK IN.
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY WE'RE NOT
VERY GOOD AT WRITING CONTRACTS
AND WE HAVE TO DO CHANGE ORDERS
ALL THE TIME I I USED TO WRITE
CONTRACTS I KNOW I WOULD ALWAYS
THAT GOOD.
AND SO THE TAXPAYER ENDS UP
PAYING MORE WHEN THEY HAD THE
BEST GROUP WORKING FOR AT THAT
TIME DOING THE WORK.
AND EXPERIENCE PEOPLE DOING THE
WORK AND SO I I KNOW ONLY
COMMEND YOU BUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY BROUGHT UP I'M
GLAD.
ESPECIALLY THE PART ABOUT COMING
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
NO GOVERNMENTAL BODY.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO JUST.
RUN AMOK AND NOT HAVE ANY
OVERSIGHT TECHNICALLY THEY HAVE
NO OVERSIGHT AT THE BORDER
REGIONS AND THEY CAN JUST DO
ANYTHING THEY WANT.
AND I WISH WE HAD ADDED THAT HIT
TO YOUR BILL THAT WE WOULD GIVE
THEM FOUR YEAR TERMS.
SO THEY WOULD LEARN.
HOW? TO TO LISTEN TO OTHER
PEOPLE AND TAKING THEIR INPUT
AND NOT JUST DO WHATEVER THEY
FELT THEY WANTED TO DO AND SO I
I WILL BE A YES.
YES AND YES.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I AM I
THINK IF WE ADDED THAT INTO THIS
WE MIGHT VIOLATE THE SINGLE
SUBJECT ROLE THAT I'M WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK ON THAT WITH YOU
IN A SEPARATE ACA I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT FEATURE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
I WHAT I WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
AUTHOR -- AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
CLEARLY BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC ISSUES
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS.
LIKE THAT -- IN SOME CASES CAN
GET WORKED OUT AS BILLS GO FORTY
SENATORS ON THE DETAILS I'M SURE
IT'LL BE APPROPRIATELY BETTER AT
THE SCHOOL COMMITTEE -- WHEN
THAT TIME COMES -- I I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTHCARE COMPETITIVENESS I
AGREE WE HAVE TO DO MORE ON COST
CONTAINMENT IN GENERAL IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO MAKE.
OUR PUBLIC SYSTEMS MORE
COMPETITIVE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S ONE AREA THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON AND IT ALSO
AGREED WITH THE SAME NUMBER.
JONES SAWYER MY EXPERIENCE ON
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE WHEN.
WE LOST A LOT OF PUBLIC WORKERS
AND WE OUTSOURCE A LOT OF OUR ON
THAT NOT ONLY WILL BE PAYING
MORE -- BUT WE WERE GETTING LESS
OUT OF IT AND THAT WERE THAT
DELTA WAS WAS PROFIT TO A
PRIVATE CONTRACTOR.
AND SO I THINK THERE IS A REALLY
OF AMER PRIMER USING.
A PUBLIC DOLLARS WE DO HAVE TO
BE COGNIZANT WHERE THEY GO BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY I THREE ONE
QUALITY WORK AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE SUPPORT OUR WORKERS
AND ABOUT THERE'S ABOUT.
COST.
FIFTY MEMBERS AND SENATORS --
THAT AS THIS BILL OF IT TO GET
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE I ADDED
AS CO AUTHORS I'M HONORED TO BE
ADDED AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR.
OF THIS BILL AND I'M VERY
PLEASED THAT ARE -- VICE CHAIR
AS WELL AS SUMMER DIEPPE ARE
ALSO BEING ADDED AS CO AUTHORS
TO SHOW THAT THIS TRULY IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO INSURING HIS ACCOUNTABILITY --
AND PROTECTION OF WORKERS AND SO --
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE TABLE AND SO MEADOW SECTOR
OF CULTURAL PLEASE ACTUALLY SOME
OF HIS OFFICE PLEASE CLOSE I'LL
TAKE THAT AS MY CLOTHES OKAY
UNLESS YOU LIKE TO READ THE
NAMES OF ALL THE CO AUTHORS.
WE'LL BE HERE FOR AWHILE THAT'S
A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE IT'S A
GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE.
QUESTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I AGREE YOU.
WILL I GET.
YEP I GONZALEZ I I JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SERVICE ALSO [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG [inaudible]
SB [inaudible]
PLEASE DON'T.
PLEASE PLEASE UPON.
RUN INTO ANY OF OUR A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PLEASE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
I HAVE A VERY ON THAT -- ONE
SENATOR ESSENTIAL [inaudible]
SB. TWO TWENTY NINE HELLO LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN.
THANK YOU.
OUR THIS BILL DEALS WITH
WHISTLEBLOWERS I WAS HERE.
A FEW YEARS AGO ON A
WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTE AND I
WANTED TO BRING THIS BECAUSE
EVERY OFFICE IN THE STATE I'M
NOT GONNA GIVE THAT LONG OF A
TALK -- THE ALRIGHT I'M GONNA
MAKE IT SHORT AND SWEET
[inaudible]
DOES YOUR NO THESE ARE JUST THE
OUTLINE OF MY TALKING POINTS.
BUT YOU KNOW THIS THESE REALLY
STATES IN LARGE MEASURE THE CORE
THE CORNER STONE PUBLIC POLICY
THAT WE ASK EMPLOYERS TO HIM.
LOOK AT THIS THERE'S ONE RIGHT
HERE THAT'S OUTLINED IN RED THAT
SAYS WHISTLE BLOWERS ARE
PROTECTED.
IT IS THE PUBLIC POLICY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO IMPLORED.
TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
TO NOTIFY THE APPROPRIATE
GOVERNMENTAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY BASICALLY TO TELL THE
TRUTH.
AND I SHARE THAT WITH YOU
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT SOME
TANGENTIAL AREA THE AS WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PAGES IN THE LABOR
CALLED THIS INFORMS ONE OF THE
BASIC ELEMENTS.
AND SO A COUPLE YEARS AGO I WAS
HERE SETTING UP A PROCESS AND
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE FOUND OUT
AFTER TALKING SOME OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE OTHER DAY.
AND IT WOULD ONE OF THE PROCESS
SEES AS TO ONCE THERE'S A FAULT
ABOUT HOW YOU TAKE THAT THE
FAULT.
AND REDUCE IT TO A JUDGMENT IS
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS HEADED WE'VE
BASICALLY IN THIS MEASURE ADDED
ON WHAT I DID A FEW YEARS AGO
HAVE AN EXPEDITED PROCESS TO
MAKE THE PRODUCT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT ONE IS A DEFAULT.
IT'S EASIER FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO ENFORCE MORE
QUICKLY.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IT WASN'T TOO LONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL -- AS STATED SO WHAT BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG WE WOULD JUST
ADD THAT -- WITH SB THREE OF SIX
A FEW YEARS AGO OF WHICH WE WERE
A CO SPONSOR THE MAIN.
THING TO DO WAS MAKE THE PROCESS
OF WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION
SIMPLER BY GRANTING THEM THAT
TEMPORARY INJUNCTIVE AUTHORITY.
TO INTERVENE BEFORE YEARS NEED
TO GO BY IN A VERY LONG VERY
EXPENSIVE DRAWN OUT COURT
PROCESS TO GET.
THEM THEIR JOBS BACK OR TO AND
THE DISCRIMINATORY ACTIVITY IN
PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS CASES AND
WHAT WE FOUND AFTER THE BILL
PASSED WAS THAT THERE WERE A FEW
AREAS THAT NEEDED TO BE TWEAKED
pPROCESS TO WORK.
AS ENVISIONED ONE OF WHICH WAS
THAT WE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
INFORMAL AS OPPOSED TO FORMAL
HEARINGS COULD BE USED THOSE ARE
ONES THAT.
EMPLOYEE DEPUTY LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS RATHER THAN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES THE
DEAL SEIZE TEN BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS
AS ARE THE EMPLOYER SO IT.
TENDS TO JUST WORK BETTER FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED IT WAS ALSO A
LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER.
THE THE FINAL ORDER CITATION IS
DEVELOP TO THE BEST GUESS WAS
THAT IT NEEDED TO GO BACK INTO
THE COURT PROCESS WHICH IS KIND
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID THE FIRST
PLACE SO.
THIS JUST ALLOWS IN THE ARM THE
DIVISION TO BETTER ENFORCE THE
CITATIONS THEMSELVES RATHER THAN
HAVING TO GO TO COURT.
SO WE ARE DRIVE UP THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA TREMELLA
I'M AN ATTORNEY FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AS WELL
AND I'M HERE TO PROVIDE ANY
QUESTIONS AS REGARDING TO
TECHNICAL FIXES.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MERRY GO USUALLY HOT.
THE CALIFORNIA INCLEMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
RIGHT BRING ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
DO HAVE A MOTION FROM A SEVEN OR
CARILLO SECOND FROM SUMMER DOES
ALSO.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ANY CLOSE SENATOR.
AS RIVAL THANK YOU SO KINDLY
THANK YOU CENTER OF SECTOR OF
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
MOTION IS DO PASS TO JUDICIARY
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING PRE UP.
CARILLO I YEP.
YEP NOT VOTING GONZALEZ JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I THREE
OF US.
THREE OF US.
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON HER.
AND SO -- WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THOSE
WHO WERE NOT PRESENT TO GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT ON
TRANSACTION.
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE AN SB --
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT ABSENT MEMBERS
CARILLO.
CARILLO II YET.
YEP HI.
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I OKAY SO I THINK
EVERYBODY ELSE CUT EVERYONE'S
CAUGHT UP EXCEPT FOR SUMMER
GONZALEZ ON THIS -- BUT SB TWO
TWENTY NUYS WILL HOLD ON FOR A
MINUTE FOR HER.
AND OTHERWISE RETURN
[inaudible]
PLEASE